hello and welcome to this video playing
mmm as we may hide off you have frequent
opponent 10 wins three draws so he never
beat me I probably was lucky in those
games it's almost impossible to get to
such a score without having some luck ok
we have them ship an ankle sloth and a 4
is an interesting line that I want to
try out yeah this is a something that I
recently have looked at together with
the student while studying a game so I
have some vague idea what to do him and
like yeah black gets annoyed would you
before if he takes on c4 I go 95 it's
not yeah it's not something I'm super
brilliant for white but I think white is
probably open slightly better him that
f.2d 5 is the right move now and it's
played by my opponent so you have to
trade now which is a bit unfortunate I
don't want to trade here but there's no
big choice c5 ok hmm that I did not
expect
okay so i think i'm going to take right
pawn takes that's not be 60 this is no
good um d takes you five whom i don't
know i can go eat for as well efore and
possibly d5 and also there's not be six
by the way i would took me a long time
to see that but i have not be six all
right and then can take c5 mmm it looks
very nice using my better development
yeah i can take with the pawn here right
how are you going to get this get this
develop them she'll come to e6 I guess I
with this and look to you one it's got
night c64 so this is it's not so bad
maybe I should get in Bishop d3 em yeah
yeah that's doing that with it sir it's
a good idea if it takes now that would
be very pleased with that so he's not
doing that but we should hear right it
was my idea so that now knight c6 I'm
able to capture so the night will not
come to deform yep it looks good it's so
not so easy to see how I'm actually
going to win this game is ruckus is
really in a you know in some trouble I
am
probably should trade him maybe he can
jam I can actually take with the rook
and scream Texas not doing much good
Queen takes this night a 2 this is
irritating me a bit but he's still you
always plays without the rook there I
don't believe it and I've got queen to
d6 right and then Queen g5 might still
be playable hmm taking a bit too long
him Queen d2 may be added to that Queen
g5 irritated me
he still has 92 right I don't have a
clear reply to that I'm not playing this
game as well him and I'm not I don't
know what I do against this move okay in
place baby just plays back yeah queen d
6 is still as the screen g5 that
irritates me okay I'm taking this is
still very good so let's get this
rolling
keep everything covered the night is
still dominating this look pretty nicely
where to put this now can always block
the Queen down Queen cannot come to g5
anymore how do I win this I don't quite
see it yet c2 may be here for up d 1
rupee 156 maybe you won't sacrifice the
exchange and hope that he's getting some
counter play going currently my king is
not so safe one minute ten now this is
this is the thing
tween before is probably also a useful
move keeping everything more covered
let's see what he does I have a feeling
that he will sacrifice the exchange okay
didn't do that so this move and rocked
your next check time marceline will come
to h5 I guess so I'm get this done
yeah I still doesn't have any any
meaningful counterplay don't I don't
quite see how I'm winning so this is
this a thing if i can trade a little bit
than everything is cool d 8 / poo it
comes to a to shoot this is whoa this is
actually getting dangerous i do should
have one ok check aha what what what the
beep ok i have seven after perpetual no
Jay that is really really bad from this
position she was completely winning of
course I and now I have to make the
stroke Jack Jack oops not resigning
right it feels a little bit like
resigning oh my god yeah yeah I did
let's see i saw that check far too late
mmm yeah I can take c 6 or whatever I
simply didn't see the check and I takes
as this this is also which issue very
bad am I kind of got nervous there with
the with the time disadvantage okay it
really happens quite a bit that I get
nervous that because I have such a great
history of sporting game said were like
a win right from the start and gather
then I'm just screwing it up oh yeah
actually I've actually made it okay
h5 is amazing okay so i was very lucky
him yeah well Vince was just everything
here Wow yeah it was actually decently
play game up to one point but then yes
c5 is losing basically he has to play b6
some some modest move this is more or
less losing the game here yeah this is
this is a position that I absolutely
must win it's not everything else would
be this bad not winning this game is
pretty pretty awful okay so he's a rope
down one basically now the easiest is
probably queen to d6 but i'm getting
always irritated by this at the rook
hangs and whatever and bishops III okay
books III is winning and yeah yes no
check or whatever but you know i always
try to play in a way that gives no
counter play and sometimes i'm doing the
opposite team this before i can also
argue but i wanted to passer but it's
all pretty much a moot point the
position is completely winning i just
have to not play what d7 and take c6 I
mean he is very passive has no nothing
and it just takes his six and it's gone
yeah and this is actually 97 seems to be
a draw still well this is this is losing
shine now chuckling perpetual yeah bad
game it shouldn't shouldn't have come to
that okay thanks for watching